le ministre de l'économie a par ailleurs
annoncé deux bonnes nouvelles pour les
sinistrés premièrement il n'y aura pas
de franchises supérieures à nice 500
francs pour les assurés christian
sautter qui a précisé ensuite qu'après
un accord avec les compagnies
d'assurances les visites d'experts ne
seront pas nécessaires si les travaux
sont inférieures à 20 mille francs
sur le front de la marée noire toujours
pas de bonnes nouvelles la pollution
progresse vers le sud
et on apprend par ailleurs que le
pompage du fioul contenu dans l'épave de
l'erika ne pourra pas être entrepris
avant plusieurs mois stéphane breitner
depuis des jours ces mêmes scènes de
ramassage du pétrole sur les plages
ce matin encore à la turballe on
s'activait pour effacer ses immenses
taches noires polluants des scènes que
l'on s'attend à revoir bientôt
encore plus au sud parce que là la
province elle se trouve maintenant au
large de talmont-saint-hilaire après
être passé au nord-est de l'île d'yeu en
l'asu lyon
elle se déplace à grande vitesse aidé
par la tente est ce qui la rapproche des
cours
le dernier survol du site où s'était
échouée l'erika n'a pas ramené de bonnes
nouvelles
des dizaines de boulettes de pétrole
remonte à la verticale de lait par une
épave dont on ne sait toujours pas dans
quel état elle se trouve hier le na'vi
abeilles supporters a quitté bayonne
avec à bord un robot téléguidé qui a
notamment servi à inspecter l'épave du
titanic par 120 mètres de fond
grâce à ses caméras et ses deux bras
articulé il pourra fournir les premières
images de la coque de l'erika et repérer
les faits s commandes exactement comme
un jeu vidéo vous avez un joystick et
toutes les fonctions de propulsion de
rotation sont commandés par ce joystick
le navire avec ses 11 hommes d'équipage
doit arriver sur sip en fin d'après midi
si la météo le permet aujourd'hui ce
sont plus de 250 km de côtes qui sont
touchés par la marée noire
et ce n'est sans doute pas fini les 20
mille tonnes de fuel encore prisonnières
dans la coque de l'erika menace les
spécialistes estiment que les opérations
de pompage ne pourront pas débuter avant
le printemps